here to respond former Director of
National Intelligence under President
Trump John Ratcliffe you have been
unequivocal uh there is nobody no
top-ranking National Security official
that knows any breach of any airspace at
all during the Trump era
you've heard from all of them Sean
they've come on one uh one after another
we've all denied it and that's why you
see the Biden Administration you know
trotting out one Alibi after another
this is the you know a cleanup on aisle
nine that we see after every one of
their National Security disasters and
there have been a lot where it's let's
blame Trump or say that the Trump
Administration did it too and in this
case Sean it falls apart from the
beginning as you correctly pointed out
your viewers know they didn't learn
about the Chinese spy balloon from the
Biden Administration they didn't learn
about it from NORAD they didn't learn
about it from the Department of Defense
they learned about it from two guys
standing in a parking lot the first guy
saw it with the naked eye the second guy
took telephoto used a telephoto lens to
take pictures that were published
commercial airline pilots sought
thousands maybe tens of thousands of
Americans saw this thing with the naked
eye as it went from one end of the
country to the other and now with the
Biden Administration tells you today is
this was happening during the Trump
Administration but apparently objects
that you could see clearly in 2023 were
there in the Trump years but no one was
able to see him I mean it's just absurd
the logic makes no sense none of this
holds up the inescapable truth is as
secretary esper said this was an
unprecedented national security breach
and disaster it was a it was a national
security Bonanza for the uh for the
Chinese Communist party and it was a
disaster for our country in terms of
what was accomplished and now even worse
to hear some Democrats trying to spin
this like it was a good thing or a coup
if it was a good thing the logic Sean
follows that if it was a good thing and
we were collecting Intelligence on China
should we all be hoping that Vladimir
Putin launches a spy balloon that will
cross the country next week and the
mullahs and Iran will do one the week
after that would be great wouldn't it no
again the Absurd logic that the Biden
Administration keeps applying you know
shows you why this National Security
team that he has around him you know
failed you at our border failed you in
Afghanistan failed you in in deterring
Putin in Ukraine and now they're trying
to sell they're tough on China no one's
buying it all right so but Biden is
saying that the Spy flight is not a
major breach uh which is stunning to me
um the fact that they were told as you
rightly point out by a guy that took a
photo of Montana is is pretty staggering
to me doesn't that show that there's a
vulnerability uh you can fly something
the size of three school buses above the
United States move it all around the
place and and it go undetected uh
wouldn't that open us up to a potential
bio weapons attack an EMP attack some
kind of even perhaps a nuclear attack
and then we have the NORAD Commander
telling us he's not ruling out aliens
and or extraterrestrial beings uh do you
ever hear about extraterrestrial beings
as Director of National Intelligence
well uh you know we do have unidentified
aerial phenomenon that's clearly not
what anything here these are slow moving
drifting you know uh the numbers two
three and four that have been shot down
recently they for all we know they may
be Sky trash but the Chinese balloon uh
spy balloon that we do know about number
one was on a dedicated Mission and it
was a major breach uh and it's it's
inescapable the damage uh that was done
to our national security and you're
seeing it you're seeing China respond to
it I mean first of all you know their
reaction to this was first to deny it
then to downplay it uh then to demand it
back and then to accuse us of doing the
same thing and you talked about it Sean
now they're getting more aggressive with
our our allies and friends in the
indo-pacific with the Philippines with
Taiwan why wouldn't they they've had
there's been no deterrence from this
Administration with respect to China and
I only see this getting worse
well we appreciate it director Ratcliffe
uh scary scenario I think of
vulnerability that I I never thought
would exist in our lifetime is is right
there hovering above our airspace uh
pretty scary uh director Ratcliffe thank
you